Florida Republicans have passed a
disgusting and I would argue completely
unenforceable pronoun Bill pronoun bill
as well as a ban on diversity programs
now I'm going to give you the details
and I'll tell you why this doesn't make
any sense but if you zoom out just a
little bit remember we've been talking
about this Florida Fiasco for months now
and aside from being completely morally
bankrupt and substantively vapid it also
seems to be the wrong strategic approach
politically for Florida Republicans to
focus so much on Disney's bad and woke
is bad and trans is bad because they
don't really have the voters on their
side to a great degree with these issues
but okay this is what they've decided to
do so what have they done the Associated
Press reports Florida Republicans pass a
bill on pronoun usage at school ban on
diversity programs anybody saying have
they banned a part of speech completely
no they're talking about gender pronouns
that differ from biological sex and I'll
tell you the exact wording in a moment
Florida Republicans on Wednesday
approved bills to ban diversity programs
and colleges and prevent students and
teachers from being required to use
pronouns that don't correspond to
someone's sex built on top priorities of
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis the two
proposals were given final passage by
the Republican super majorities DeSantis
is expected to sign it
um okay so what does it do the Senate
Wednesday voted to expand the law
critics called don't say gay a major
calling card of DeSantis with a sweeping
bill that prevents School staffers or
students from being required to refer to
People by pronouns that don't respond to
the correspond to the person's sex it
also bans classroom instruction on
gender identity and sexual orientation
up to the eighth grade legally
reinforcing the DeSantis move to
prohibit such lessons in all grades it
also strengthens the system in which
people can Lodge challenges against
school books another disantemonious de
sanctimonious initiative all right so
there is a problem here okay and I know
many of you already identify it the only
way to know whether you were using the
pronouns that correspond to biological
birth sex is to know what genitals
someone has how on Earth would teachers
ascertain that and so when you say well
you just can't force the teachers to use
pronouns that don't correspond to the
genitalia of the individual
and I guess they're saying the birth
genitalia right there's another story
when you talk about gender affirming
surgery but let's not even delve into
that right now you're saying you can't
require them well how is anyone to know
whether what is being asked of them with
regard to pronouns matches the genitals
without taking a look at the genitals or
or what requiring a birth certificate so
obviously this is a provision that's
discriminatory to the trans Community
it's harmful to the trans Community it's
also completely impractical in every
single way because you're telling
teachers in order to know
about whether the pronouns you're using
are the right ones
you I guess have to ascertain biological
sex by looking at people are they
supposed to ask students for medical
records before addressing them by the
correct pronouns so this is not only a
ridiculous virtue signal against trans
people for the anti-trans community to
look and say oh we like what you're
doing it is a logistical and practical
nightmare for educators and it's not
feasible to enforce and of course it
goes against the very principles of
inclusivity and acceptance that we
should promote and be promoting in our
schools this doesn't mean by the way
this doesn't mean or it doesn't even
relate in any way to whether someone
born biologically male who identifies as
a woman should be allowed to be on the
girls wrestling team that's a totally
separate question it has nothing to do
with this now I also briefly want to
talk about the ban on diversity programs
because that's also a part of this even
though it's less cartoonish although
still destructive
it's equally concerning diversity
programs are designed to promote
inclusivity and to promote understanding
among different cultures and communities
the Wright loves to say that those
programs actually suppress speech bully
people
Etc to the extent that you give me an
example of that I am on your side and I
will be against it you all know if
you've been listening to this program
for a while that I don't go for that
stuff when the left goes too far as the
right loves to say I'll just tell you
yeah I don't agree with this this is not
in the spirit of progressivism this is
not in the spirit of
um uh libertarian progressivism of the
style that I and so many other
Progressive support those instances are
relatively rare and when you say no
diversity programs whatsoever you're
Banning programs that actually provide
significant value and they promote
understanding among different groups in
a way that is completely not it's not
only harmless it's a positive thing
um this is what Florida Republicans are
now focused on I believe that not only
is it wrong morally
but it's also a strategic mistake in
that they're overplaying their hand that
second part it will take some time for
us to get an answer are they overplaying
their hand we will soon see but one of
the next questions which was raised by
someone in our audience is what follows
this and one possibility is that they go
after LGBT teachers I want to talk about
that next one of our sponsors is short
form short form makes the world's best
guides to non-fiction books and not only
does short form Summarize each
non-fiction book itself into key points
that you can cover in just a few minutes
they have all sorts of interactive
exercises to help you apply the ideas to
what you've read to retain more the
guide to each book also includes
intellectual insights comparing and
contrasting the book to other prominent
books about the same topic so that you
can contextualize the book and
understand the controversies and the
disagreements they also have books
across every non-fiction genre from
economics and politics to science and
health I was recently checking out James
clear's Atomic habits on short form of
course they have the guide but they also
have highlights they also include other
similar books about habits and
developing a routine with differences
and similarities super super useful and
a lot more than just a summary of the
book there are new guides and articles
released every week and short form is
giving my audience a free trial plus 25
off a subscription which is a 50 value
so for the price of a book per month you
get access to thousands go to
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below